nice to have you guys here um i'm so
excited for this docu-series i feel like
it was uh made for me as a queer person
who got married on halloween last year
um so what made you guys decide to bring
this monster to life so to speak well
the monster was really born out of
shutters interest in and telling stories
uh about the horror genre from
marginalized people's point of view they
had this fantastic documentary called
horror noir which is about the history
of black people and horror films and
they knew they wanted to do a sequel and
about the queer community so
we have to tip our hats to shutter so
there's so many like exciting uh
interviews in this thing um from having
drag queen alaska on the cover to
um
jennifer's body director karen zuma what
are you excited about for the series i
was like well kim pierce was really
exciting yes yes of course
i am standing here so what are you gonna
say
um
i mean there's so many people i i think
it's hard to narrow it down i think we
had the cast of yellow jackets a bunch
of them came in it was super fun
and um
i really enjoyed um
oh shoot not then my my name my my
brain's blanking out on the name um what
is the star of all the gregor rocky
movies james
i james was a great interview it's it's
like he really kind of got the fight
back of the new queer cinema movement
and i i really enjoyed that
but i'll uh let you guys keep telling i
think one of the
happiest surprises that we got in terms
of interviewees was oz perkins talking
about
his father's legacy
and
you know what it was like for a closeted
queer man to navigate hollywood
and also his family in a really intimate
way that felt like something that
i hadn't seen before nobody's had that
conversation with oz and we were so
honored to be able to have that
conversation about anthony perkins in a
way that really gave dimension to his
experience as a closeted actor in the
40s 50s and 60s so as queer people were
like frequently drawn to genre fiction
sci-fi horror
what you name it
what do you think makes horror so
inherently queer
well it's you know
all being monsters i don't know if i
speak for these monsters but uh you know
uh look i certainly think in a culture
that has a normativity heteronormativity
a gender normativity
when you do not fit naturally into that
normativity particularly in prior
generations when you're coming of age
and you don't see a reflection of
yourself you become very astute at
looking between the lines and figuring
out oh i think that might be me i think
that might be a future me so i can just
say for myself because i'm like trans
butch genderqueer
homosexual maybe everything i was very
much looking between the lines and so i
think what i've found is by talking to
these guys who are brilliant and they've
done this great documentary and seeing
all these amazing interviews it's like
i'm finding my tribe that all these
these layers you know of being able to
see ourselves represented and to read
ourselves into existence until we can
actually make ourselves into existence
so i think that you you have a very uh
creative uh audienceship that's that's
creating themselves in it and then we
can get into the specifics of which
monsters and horror that we all respond
to like you said we frequently look for
representation where it isn't um or
where it's hidden between the lines um
was there a particular uh
moment in pop culture or like a movie or
television series or even character that
helped you realize your own queerness
along the way i don't know if it helped
me realize my own queerness but i feel
like when i watched scream when it came
out i i felt like there's something
different here but i don't know what it
is i know that it i know i relate to
this more than many of the other things
i've seen
and you know there's kevin williamson's
behind it and he's a gay writer so
it just the gayness is in there even
though it's not necessarily
um you know
part of the story
and i think that
for me that was just so
i don't it just made me feel different
like i was like oh i like horror again
now now i'm seeing things that are fun
and have a little bit of
you know just
secret queerness and maybe not so secret
queerness but
you know look jekyll and hyde you know
if you're
what i was which is a lot a young
bisexual lesbian who was genderqueer
trans butch and the idea of i'm going to
dress up one way and i'm going to go out
into society and i'm going to be a
successful doctor but then at night i'm
going to go out you know when i'm going
to be this other version of myself it's
a completely queer experience of being
able to move through gender and through
sexual preference and then i have to
throw in mary shelley's frankenstein i
am the monster you know but but it's a
beautiful monster and a vulnerable
monster and a monster that really wants
to be loved and i'd really believe that
i'm so proud of these guys because
they've worked so hard to bring so many
voices into the discussion that we've
never heard before that really are
bringing to life why we are in love with
these movies and what they mean to us
one of the interviews that we had with a
a trans woman who talked about
how the first time that she saw herself
in horror was the exorcist because she
was a
young girl whose body was taken over by
a male presence in the form of puberty
and it took her 20 years to exercise
that presence and reclaim her true
gender so i think when you're
you're looking at that sort of metaphor
and interpretation of the text
it really is about
what you're bringing to the table as an
audience member
so what would you say you're the most
excited for people to take away from
this docu-series when they when they
finally get to see it i think i want
people to
really think about
what it is to have queer community and
community that surrounds you and people
that
um
you can relate to and and also have this
out there for people who are struggling
in the world who don't have a community
and don't have a place to be
and and to kind of rile everybody up
let's let's you know push some
boundaries
hell yeah and i really think to imagine
yourself into existence
i think if you don't exist in the texts
that are being given to you
go ahead and project yourself onto that
which is what we all had to do and if
they are there and they're latent pull
them up and and make a celebration of
that and then i love the idea of queer
community it's just like find your tribe
because your tribe's all over and i
think that's what's been so fun about
coming in and doing the interviews i've
known steak forever i've known you
forever and it's just like oh my god
this is so much fun i love
understanding your personal connection
you know you keep bringing up scream and
i'm just like that's so cool because
that wasn't my experience so yeah
i i think
our our main goal with this is to
provide a
experience for the audience that
acknowledges what they were feeling that
may not be text and to provide an
opportunity to own the horror genre in a
way that feels sometimes very horribly
and and very heteronormative and
kind of toxically masculine in a way but
its roots and its foundations are all in
the queer experience whether that's mary
shelley or bram stoker or oscar wilde or
james whale or any of the myriad writers
that work with hitchcock there were
always queer people telling queer
stories they're just different levels of
obfuscation exactly absolutely i find
myself saying all the time that horror
belongs to gay people so uh
i am so excited for this docu-series um
and let's just end on a fun one what's
your favorite horror movie uh i'm torn
between the shining and
alien i think there's there's queer
coding in both of those films uh there's
definitely something very relatable for
a lot of
uh
people who identify as as queer or
special or abnormal in danny's
experience dealing with an abusive
father who wants to squash
what is special or unique about
danny and
so that's always resonated very strongly
with me
well so for me it's definitely the
shining and scat man crothers
and danny right finding whoa
that's a horror thing we know that we're
inhabited here something's happening
um
you know i don't know what was that
scavenge crothers when he talks about
the shine and it's just this idea of
these two people who seem very different
actually have this deep commonality and
it's a special power and it's a
perception and it's a wisdom about the
world which is very much i think what
it's like to be queer in a world that
doesn't accommodate you and doesn't
represent you again you have to birth
yourself into existence and find your
tribe and that's that's what he's doing
they're having a very queer relationship
in my eyes
and i think i'm really excited
about now where we're getting to see
series that are made by women with women
in it um and and clearly queer like
yellow jackets and
killing eve things that you know as a
younger person i didn't get to see
if i did see even we're doing a whole
episode on dangerous women
most of it is written by men most of
it's directed by men but
for me in the last five years they're
suddenly starting to be more content
that i can relate more to because
it is actually made by women well uh
thank you guys so much for coming and
chatting with us uh i cannot wait to
watch the docu-series when it comes to
shutter this fall
you